you have such hardcore fans your show
has such hardcore fans you probably have
to be careful about spoilers there must
be some littles a week it wants spoilers
there must be some that are desperately
afraid you're going to tell them a
spoiler when they don't want to hear it
and then else we have like because the
the show is based on these amazing books
by George Martin and they're so we have
these fans that have read the books and
they're very protective about it and
they also like to to know more than
anyone else and I I did this thing with
spoilers because we're not allowed to
say anything of course and I would never
say anything but but sometimes it's fun
to just tease them a little bit and I
was in Stockholm and I was doing this
thing this pressed for HBO Nordic as
it's called there and at the end of this
interview I was in this hotel room and
though I saw this stuffed animal a duck
yeah and I pulled it up and I said oh
this is just a little spoiler for the
book readers this duck think about it
and then and then I forgot about it then
a friend called me what's that thing
about a duck and I was like what he was
online and then I went online and there
was like all these all these you know
they were debating it and there's these
guys think I know exactly what that is
that's awesome but but you and
completely it's completely random it was
you do anything you could pick up a
carrot and go look for this and then
they'll be like I know what that means
exactly exactly what's so mean no it's
apologize it was just now don't you
should apologize I love it I love it
yeah nice boy lucky give us any spoilers
tonight way I do I mean do you want any
how come on they'll probably fire me but
there's I mean you know the Dragons yeah
and you know Jamie and Cersei they had
this incestuous relationship will the
Dragons too
[Laughter]
[Applause]